je savais déjà qu'on était dans une
France d'assistée maintenant je vois
qu'on nous sommes dans une France de
fragile donc je ne suis pas surprise par
rapport à ça moi par exemple profession
libérale ça ne me viendrait pas à
l'esprit d'être malade parce que même si
je suis malade j'ai rien qui tombe je
suis pas payé donc il ne faut surtout
pas que je sois malade donc même si il
se trouve que je suis jamais malade en
fait on est malade parce que on est là
on est malade parce qu'on veut glander
chez soi et avoir la paye qui tombe
voilà pourquoi on est malade parce que
un rhume c'est quoi c'est un rhume une
angine et on va pas bosser mais c'est
quoi ces gens qui foutent rien c'est
quoi ces glandus ces assistés c'est
feignasse non mais c'est pas possible
comment vous explique avec moi
professionnel mais confrères professions
libérale ne sont officiellement jamais
malade alors bonsoir Sarah
on a beaucoup parlé aujourd'hui bien
évidemment avec cette alors est-ce un
dérapage ta première question j'ai la
voix cassée je suis malade comme j'ai
dit que j'étais jamais malade
la voix cassée je rappelle que vous êtes
marié
et surtout si voilà ça n'a plus
d'intérêt de divorcer puisque je n'ai
plus en haut alors allez-y
est-ce que c'est un dérapage tout ça a
fait là on est sérieux 2 secondes c'est
vrai que les propos quand on est dans
quand on décide comme ça sont assez
violents très honnêtement c'est quoi
c'est feignant c'est que c'est un
dérapage quand c'est sorti du contexte
je vais rappeler le contexte un sondage
18 34 ans il ne viennent pas travailler
lorsqu'ils ont un rhume une angine et
des problèmes psychologiques moi dans la
séquence j'ai écarté les problèmes
psychologiques je parle de un rhume une
angine donc oui quand on ne travaille
pas et qu'on se met en arrêt maladie
pour un rhume ou une angine on est un
peu une feignasse alors feignasse
c'était peut-être un peu exagéré mais on
est aux Grandes Gueules donc les Grandes
Gueules qu'est-ce que c'est on n'est pas
chez France Culture il m'invite jamais
on est dans une émission on a la liberté
d'expression on n'est pas dans une
société aseptisée où on ne peut plus
rien rien dire et je remercie à la
Marshall et Olivier Truchot donc les
grandes gueules de m'avoir prises comme
gros
vous êtes en activité avec eux
apparemment donc voilà merci à eux mais
c'est vrai moi en fait merci à eux de me
laisser dire ce que je veux sans me
filtrer en offre en disant à temps va
pas heurter les gens on va quand même
redescendre sinon dans 10 ans
il y a eu la sortie sur l'écologie il y
a eu la solution les Bains parce que les
gens se heurtent de tout alors après si
j'ai pu offenser des gens je présente
mes excuses c'est même pas le souhait
puisque dans les Grandes Gueules
non mais il y avait un son de micro je
pense que vous n'êtes pas d'accord ah
moi je suis pas du tout d'accord parce
que tout toutes les vis sont différentes
et que vous pouvez pas insulter comme ça
les Français en leur disant que c'est
des feignants que c'est des glandus vous
vous avez votre vie vous arrivez au
boulot le matin vous avez une angine
vous allez vous allez le soir derrière
votre bureau votre ordinateur c'est
votre vie vous êtes jeune dans la force
de l'âge vous savez des gens par exemple
moi si j'ai une angine ou un rhume je ne
peux pas aller travailler
et alors il y a des mecs de 25 ans qui
conduisent des camions par exemple il y
a des caissières qui font des métiers
physiques quand tu as une angine tu as
la tête qui tourne tu peux pas aller
ranger dans les rayons être caissière
chaque parcours de vie il y a des gens
qui ont des qui ont des handicaps qui
ont des kystes sous les bras et quand
ils ont des angines ça se multiplié par
10 par 100 la douleur faut pas prendre
votre cas vous qui est assis dans votre
bureau et tant mieux pour vous dans la
force de l'âge de dire que les gens
profitent des arrêts de maladie oui on
sait qu'il y a des profiteurs des arrêts
de maladies on le sait ça
mais il faut pas dire que les Français
sont des glandus des feignasses parce
que toutes les vis sont différentes vous
vous avez votre vie qui vous pousse à
dire ça mais il y a des gens qui font
des métiers physiques il y a des gens
qui ont besoin d'être en pleine forme
pour pratiquer leur travail il y a des
gens qui mettent 1h15 pour aller dans
les transports le matin tu peux pas te
permettre d'avoir la tête qui tourne et
de tomber dans le RER parce que tu as
pas pris tes cachet parce que tu as pris
trop de cachets ou que tu as une angine
je suis pas d'accord je trouve vos
propos sont scandaleux et insultants
très insultant
[Applaudissements]
n'a pas besoin de moi que pour être son
avocate
mais effectivement elle est dans une
émission qui s'appelle Les Grandes
Gueules comme dans TPMP où il faut avoir
des avis qui sont pas tiède et des avis
extrêmement tranchés avec des vrais
punchlines et là en l'occurrence elle te
la redit elle ne parlait pas des cas
d'espèces que tu viens de citer c'est à
dire la personne en 4 ans oui mais la
personne qui a un vrai souci etc là elle
parlait des abus c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui effectivement juste parce que il a
un petit peu mal à la tête il va pas
aller travailler c'est pour ça qu'on
fait du mal à la tête s'il doit faire
une heure de transport et qu'il a mal à
la tête et que ça s'aggrave et qui tombe
dans la merde
lui il est malade et lui il est pas ce
que tu dis le degré du malade je pense
qu'elle va juger on parlait des abus et
l'intitulé de la question je sais pas si
on l'a vu c'était la France un pays de
fragile donc je réponds dans les mêmes
termes que
l'antiquités des feignasses mais ils
sont tous avocat comme vous il y a des
gens ils ont besoin d'être en pleine
forme pour aller travailler le matin
pour emmener les enfants à l'école ils
commencent peut-être pas tous à 9h30 du
matin comme vous les avocats du mat ils
plaident peut-être à minuit 1h et
peut-être tard mais ils ont pas tous la
même vie que vous les Français donc
quand vous venez à la radio pour
expliquer que les Français c'est des
assistés que c'est des feignages
c'est vous vous avez choisi il y a des
gens qui peuvent pas travailler 7 jours
sur 7 qui sont salariés et qu'on des
métiers de pénibilité c'est ça qu'il
faut entendre il y a des métiers où il
faut être en pleine forme pour aller
travailler même à moindre heureusement
c'est mon point de vue il faut pas
insulter les gens c'est tout alors là
vraiment a raison c'est que c'est vrai
que c'est un travail très physique et là
on peut pas toujours
plus compliqué non c'est pas c'est pas
que moi c'est pas c'est pas mon cas
c'est pas parce que moi je suis
chauffeur-livreur et que je peux pas
prendre de cachet je peux pas conduire
donc je dois m'arrêter oui mais c'est
pas que moi je dis que c'est la vie de
plein de gens la vie de plein de gens
elle est faite de se lever tôt qu'il
faut être vous prenez un agent de sécu
qui est debout toute la journée il peut
pas lui venir avec une angine il est
obligé de faire un arrêt avec plein de
métiers peut-être pas s'il doit
intervenir vite s'il a la tête qui
tourne s'il doit se séparer une bagarre
il y a plein de métiers
34 ans et voilà moi je suis on a entendu
c'est que il y a des arguments mais
c'est vrai que voilà c'est certaines
personnes vont vous dire réellement que
effectivement avec un rhume angine on
peut aller bosser
mais on peut bosser avec une entorse pas
un problème dans la caricature
c'est pas ce qui vous caractérise le
plus quand même mettre un petit peu de
la provocation là
alors oui mais les propos de Madame sont
ahurissants il y a 40 % des salariés je
suis choqué allez c'est comme ça que
vous commencez toujours quand je viens
je suis extrêmement choqué plus que
jamais par vos propos voilà pour ça des
salariés français on est en arrêt de
maladie l'année dernière parmi eux les
gens fragiles des aidants et beaucoup de
jeunes ces jeunes là aujourd'hui que
vous foul ils sont ils expriment un
mal-être ils sont mâles ils ont un
burnout ils sont dans des situations
difficiles ils prennent des boulots
compliqués et je vous signale que s'il
s'arrête c'est parce que le médecin juge
que leur situation leur santé nécessite
de se protéger pour pas qu'il y ait de
drame et vous vous dites
ce sont des glandus
bientôt vous allez explorer jeune et
bientôt vous allez nous dire j'ai jamais
dit ça ce matin alors madame les jeunes
sont en situation de précarité fragile
au travail et du rhume et une angine une
angine c'est une maladie grave arrêtez
c'est terrible ce que vous dites là vous
êtes en train de manger
vous pouvez pas travailler mais vous
aussi vous faites pareil quand on a une
angine on est allé on s'arrête on a 40
degrés mais vous êtes malade vous êtes
malade
ade très humide vous êtes fous vous êtes
vous prenez un petit chat dans la gorge
actuellement je suis déplacé vous êtes
en train d'inquiéter au fait que les
jeunes aujourd'hui demandent des arrêts
maladie bidon
alors oui monsieur non oui moi je pense
que c'est facile quand on est avocate on
gagne très bien sa vie qu'on travaille
sur les plateaux télé de dire
mais c'est pas les pathologies mais je
parle même pas de salaire c'est un
métier qui est épanouissant aussi il y a
des métiers qui sont moins épanouissants
que ça déjà premièrement il y a des gens
qui sont plus faibles psychologiquement
et physiquement que d'autres et là vous
avez raison d'un côté c'est que vous
dites qu'il y a une sorte d'abus
peut-être qu'il y a de l'abus mais je
pense qu'il y a des gens qui ont moins
de remords à se mettre en arrêt maladie
parce que il ne respecte pas le système
parce que le système ne respecte pas ils
sont mal payés ils sont pas épanouis ils
ont aucune perspective d'évolution donc
qu'est-ce que vous en foutez vous mettez
en arrêt maladie quand vous gagnez pas
votre vie vous faites un travail qui
vous saoule moi je comprends que ces
gens-là bah quand ils ont un petit rhume
voilà ils ont moins de remords à se
mettre en arrêt maladie est-ce que ce
sont des assistés des glandus et des
feignasses pour autant je ne pense pas
Delphine le problème c'est que quand on
parle avec les chefs d'entreprise
très souvent ça leur arrive ils sont
totalement dépités parce qu'ils disent
ben voilà j'ai beaucoup de mal avec mes
employés
ils viennent deux jours et puis se
mettre en arrêt maladie on n'arrive pas
à les rappeler parce que voilà donc
c'est ça aussi qu'il faut entendre et je
pense clairement qu'aujourd'hui vu qu'on
arrive tellement facilement en allant
chez le médecin avoir un arrêt de
travail je pense vraiment que 50% la
moitié des arrêts de travail je pense
que c'est du flan parce que
les délirants votre chiffre il est
complètement délirant pas dire ça
pourquoi
je pense parce que 50% c'est beaucoup
d'éléments
j'ai dit je pense parce que quand vous
allez chez le docteur c'est très très
simple de faire un arrêt de travail et
encore une fois si vous mettez du côté
des salariés voilà mais il faut regarder
voilà le droit du travail c'est pas
seulement des droits c'est aussi des
obligations c'est aussi des devoirs et
aujourd'hui on ne parle pas assez des
chefs d'entreprise qui n'arrivent plus à
recruter et quand ils recrute et ben
c'est des gens qui sont bancal et qui se
mettent en arrêt du travail parce que
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne et
jamais en difficulté toute entreprise au
passage c'est vrai qu'on a tous vécu ça
le médecin qui vous dit je vous fais un
petit arrêt
de situation qu'on a tous alors après on
n'est pas obligé d'accepter
beaucoup parce que maintenant nous
oblige à avoir des médecins traitants
c'est plus comme avant où tu allais voir
n'importe quel médecin il t'arrêter
maintenant tu as ton médecin traitant
c'est ils sont surveillés ils sont
beaucoup surveillés moi je pense que le
chiffre de 50% c'est beaucoup est élevé
je pense pas que les Français oui oui il
y a de la vue on le sait tu trouveras
toujours quelqu'un qui va abuser du
système et il y a des gens qui ont
travaillé pour payer ceux qui foutent
rien comme ça il y en a ils veulent rien
faire il y en a ils veulent pas
travailler mais la plupart des gens
c'est comme ça quand ils s'arrête il
s'arrête pour de vrai et tes chefs
d'entreprise qui arrive pas à trouver de
personnel et qui disent ouais il reste
deux jours il est parti c'est peut-être
parce que tu l'as payé au lance-pierre
c'est peut-être parce que ta société
faut la remettre en question c'est
peut-être parce que c'est une boîte de
merde et qui reste 2 ans 2 jours et qui
veut se barrer après il faut payer les
mecs aussi
tu le connais quand tu vas dans une
entreprise donc tu peux pas dire je suis
sous payé je me mets en arrêt maladie au
bout de 2 jours puisque tu sais tu sais
où tu mets les pieds aujourd'hui des
métiers il y en a plein aujourd'hui
pour signer un contrat de travail qui va
on te fait l'entretien d'embauche tout
va bien tout est beau tout est propre et
ensuite tu rentres dans l'entreprise tu
rentres dans le monde de l'entreprise tu
découvres tes collègues tu découvres une
pelle une pénibilité qu'on t'avais pas
expliqué et c'est comme ça c'est la vie
c'est le monde du travail on va demander
comme ça américaine en Amérique
parenthèse le temps du travail c'est
réduit à la pension Congo ça n'existe
pas donc et vous conseille pas le
système américain
tout d'abord je voudrais juste dire que
j'ai pas trop et que c'était un dérapage
je trouve ça très bien que ça à Salman
donne son avis on a une liberté
d'expression qu'il faut protéger et donc
ça c'est très bien elle pose toujours
des sujets elle met le doigt sur des
sujets de société
je ne suis absolument pas d'accord avec
ce qu'elle a dit je pense que sur le
fond il y a un vrai problème de sens
dans notre société les gens font des
jobs ils ne savent plus quelle est leur
place dans la société ils gagnent des
salaires de misère il y a une inflation
qui va en plus s'accroître les gens vont
être dans des situations de précarité
terrible le 10 du mois et c'est comme ça
que les gilets jaunes ont commencé le 10
du mois les gens n'ont même plus à
manger voilà et donc effectivement la
motivation n'est plus là elle est plus
matérielle parce que les salaires sont
trop bas et elle n'est plus
intellectuelle parce que c'est vrai que
il y a plein de jobs surtout dans les
disques de la tranche dont vous parlez
les 18-34 ans qui sont des petits jobs
qui ne sont pas forcément épanouissants
et vous avez dit dans la même émission
que vous ça ne vous concernait pas mais
vous vous faites un job épanouissant
en arrêt j'étais pas de votre
rémunération je dis que vous êtes
peut-être passionné par votre métier et
c'est vrai que les jobs des jeunes qui
sont concernés par vos propos c'est pas
le cas et c'est vrai que c'est une
chance énorme moi j'ai été passionnée
par mon métier toute ma vie c'est je le
considère pas comme un travail et quand
on aime son métier on n'a pas
l'impression d'aller travailler et on y
va même si on est malade mais quand on
fait des jobs qui sont pas prestigieux
voilà il y a pas besoin d'avoir un
travail prestigieux pour aimer son
travail malheureusement
alors vous vous travaillez vous
travaillez au Vélodrome
donc c'est les jours de match
S
de médecins et puis les médecins ils
prescrits pour vous il y a de la bulle
ah oui c'est clair c'est clair et je
suis totalement d'accord avec Delphine
pour vous il va quand vous discutez avec
des avec des potes qui sont jeunes voilà
ils disent voilà ils mettent en arrêt
maladie parce que comme ça tout le monde
fait ça maintenant en tout cas à
Marseille
peut-être chez les les trentenaires 40
Nairo et mais peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
la jeune génération a besoin un peu plus
de cadre et tout et pense peut-être pour
la facilité de malgré tout des arrêts de
travail facile
non mais il y a de la bûche chez les
employeurs aussi quand un employeur
propose un salaire très bas voir un SMIC
à son salarié je peux vous dire qu'il en
a rien à [ __ ] de sa vie savoir comment
il va se loger comment il va faire ses
courses et cetera donc la bulle est
peut-être du côté des salariés mais
encore une fois parce qu'ils ne sont pas
respectés bien souvent et ce serait bien
que les les employeurs traitent de
manière humaine tous leurs salariés et
je pense que ça éviterait ce genre de
problème si ils se mettent en arrêt
entièrement dans la rue
et ne pas avoir envie de travailler ça
veut dire qu'on n'est pas épanoui au
travail donc respecter dans les deux
sans raison c'est pas la même chose
quand tu touches 1300 balles et que tu
vas pas bosser deux trois jours quatre
jours tu vas perdre peut-être 80 100
euros c'est énorme c'est une somme
énorme que vous en profession libérale
comme vous avez dit en avocat vous allez
perdre des milliers en honoraires c'est
pas la même chose les enjeux sont pas
les mêmes c'est pas c'est pas comparable
en fait c'est pas comparable et après
sur les jeunes moi pour moi 30 ans tu es
pas tu es pas jeune tu es tu étais en
place donc 18 34 18 non mais vous avez
dit votre truc c'est les assister les
feignants c'est 18-34
d'ailleurs un mot qu'on entend souvent
chez les politiques hein d'ailleurs qui
croient proche
quand on écoute les gens et moi ce
qu'ils vivent on se dit que on était
assisté en face c'est quand même très
compliqué pour une majorité de Français
mais il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
décident de ne pas travailler pour
bénéficier de beaucoup d'aide alors
qu'il y en a qui galèrent pour gagner
2000 euros qui bénéficie de rien là la
raison
juste pardonnez-moi mais vous pouvez pas
dire que ce que dit Anissa et il faut
c'est de l'expérience sur le terrain
que ça vous énerve je peux l'entendre
mais dites pas qu'elle dit des conneries
que tout ça n'existe pas
c'est ce qu'elle vit ok je dis que
partir du postulat que une énorme
majorité de jeunes va faire des arrêts
de travail bidon auprès d'un médecin ça
me semble grave voilà après je comptais
pas ce que vous vivez je dis que ça me
semble pas représenter une génération et
je trouve que pour revenir sur vous
mettre tranquillement assis sur nos
magnifiques fauteuils de chroniqueurs
critiquer des gens qui souffrent en les
accusant de faire des arrêts de travail
bidon c'est pas digne voilà c'est pas
digne de l'avocate que vous faites et
que vous êtes et je trouve que c'est
mépriser les 18 34 ans qui souffrent
c'est facile comme ça de les pour fendre
d'une tirade sans doute habile non les
jeunes ne sont ni glandus ni assistés ni
feignants ils s'offrent beaucoup madame
alors ils n'ont pas à manger dans les
universités voilà ils n'ont pas à manger
les jeunes ils font la queue caricaturer
mais pour des centaines de mètres de
file d'attente pour avoir à manger les
jeunes voilà c'est madame qui est jeune
vous tient un discours inverse
les parcours de vie
elle travaille une journée elle va à
Marseille au stade Vélodrome servir des
papalouillés c'est pas ça la vie c'est
pas ça c'est son parcours de vieille ils
sont parcours de vie c'est pas la vérité
elle est en ce moment qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait elle travaille elle va au stade
Vélodrome au soir des matchs servir des
Verts c'est ça vienne elle travaille une
journée ou deux jours dans le dans la
semaine il y a que deux matchs on est
d'accord une ou deux matchs tu
travailles pas de 7 jours sur 7
Vélodrome
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord mais
il faut pas
le contraire mais faut pas dire
c'est quelque chose
dis les exemples que vous donnez à tout
le monde fait genre
mais les gens qui font des arrêts des
arrêts de travail c'est pas en fonction
du domaine au secteur d'activité c'est
pas en fonction du salaire c'est c'est
des gens c'est des façons de penser
d'avoir éduqué c'est des façons d'être
donc voilà c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il faudrait redonner voilà soit on a
la conscience professionnelle soit on
l'a pas que ce soit à 800 900 ou 4000
euros c'est exactement la même chose je
pense que dans l'éducation il faudrait
redonner le la fier le goût de le
travail et le goût de l'effort
le mec le mec nous expliquer on va on va
laisser de côté la provoc quel était le
message parce que derrière
vous dites le Burnin c'est une maladie
le rhume il y a des abus quand on
demande un arrêt de travail quand on a
un simple rhume mais c'est une
généralité après
de cette provocation
après il y a des exceptions bien sûr les
personnes vulnérables évidemment que
c'est normal de prendre un arrêt il y a
des exceptions comme remise parier mais
que parfois comme dit Anissa il y a
vraiment des abus on rentre de soirée on
n'a pas envie on demande en arrêt c'est
un abus et la laitue en question c'était
la France un pays de fragile je le
rappelle parce que parfois ça a du mal à
rentrer les missions s'appelle Les
Grandes Gueules j'aurais été chez
quotidien il m'invite jamais bon
j'aurais parlé différemment j'aurais dit
nous sommes dans une société ou
peut-être éventuellement il faudrait
assainir le système